il est très délicat d'aborder le
problème de l'inceste mais il est de
notre devoir de vous en parler car le
phénomène n'est pas isolé en france ne
s'agit pas de vous montrer des
témoignages ce ne serait pas pudique
mais là encore d'essayer de comprendre
comment les comprendre sans leur donner
la parole nous sommes en
1978 et à en croire noël mamère le grand
public n'est pas prêt à entendre des
témoignages pourtant quelques années
plus tard à la télévision les victimes
d'inceste vont briser l'omerta mon père
a commencé à nous mettra les autres
enfants en bas et c'est comme ça que ça
a commencé donc il nous a touchés moi
personnellement j'avais l'âge 8 en 8 ans
de ma forêt à ce moment là
puis ça a continué il n'a jamais eu de
rapports sexuels avec moi mais tout le
reste presque j'y suis passé donc
jusqu'à mes 18 ans en 1984 anne-marie à
visage découvert et l'hymne des
premières à parler à chaque fois les
témoignages de victimes créé l'événement
comme eva thomas sur le plateau des
dossiers de l'écran en 1986 mais ça
s'est passé une nuit quand je me suis
réveillé
je
j'avais un trou noir dans la tête un
blanc dans ma tête je ne savais plus ce
qui s'était passé j'étais horriblement
angoissé mais je savais seulement
j'avais le souvenir de mon père sur moi
et c'est tout
j'ai mis trente ans à retrouver la
mémoire de cette nuit là
au fil des années les témoignages se
multiplient les français prennent
conscience de la réalité de l'inceste et
les médias s'en font les relais il faut
en parler il faut oser en parler malgré
la gêne les tabous et le risque aussi de
briser des silences qui ne sont pas
toujours ceux de l'ignorance car la
révélation d'un inceste brise une
famille et c'est souvent ce qui empêche
les victimes de parler mais il ya une
autre forme de violence sexuelle dont on
parle moins l'inceste il ne fait huer la
une des journaux pourtant ils
représentent 55% des viols
elle s'absentait 1h30 environ
donc moi j'étais déjà couché il rentre
dans ma chambre et repartez un petit peu
avant que ma mère arrive
mon temps je me suis demandé si tous les
pères faisait ça pour accompagner ses
prises de parole dans les années 80 des
campagnes de sensibilisation sont
diffusées à la télévision pour que les
gens viendront puis se sortir de la race
du silence il faut les aider à dépasser
la honte c'est le but de cette campagne
est aujourd'hui encore c'est le but de
cette nouvelle plateforme en ligne un
site et toutes les victimes d'inceste à
prendre la parole aujourd'hui je
témoigne pour moi mais surtout pour
protéger les enfants des violences
sexuelles et notamment de l'inceste vous
aussi vous pouvez témoigner ensemble
sortons du silence
[Musique]